Hi everyone, and welcome to Biology Professor.
Today, I want to talk to you about the life cycle
of a pretty terrible parasite called hookworm.
Now, hookworm is a parasite, specifically a
kind of helminth, which means a worm, which we can
tell from its name. So hookworm is a parasite that
infects upwards of 800 million people per year
globally, so certainly a serious parasite for many
people's experiences. The worm is particularly
noteworthy because it actually penetrates right
through unbroken skin of the host. So a lot of
times, various pathogens will actually need a
cut in the skin to be able to enter through the
skin. Hookworm doesn't need that. It can actually
burrow right through healthy unbroken skin. And
ultimately it lives in the small intestine where
it attaches to the intestinal walls, sometimes for
years, and sucks the host's blood. Now this leads
to some pretty severe side effects resulting
from anemia, that is the blood is sucked,
blood is where a lot of our body's iron is
stored, and so hosts get anemia, which is
an iron deficiency and the anemia then goes on
to cause its own problems, including delayed
growth and delayed mental development or mental
impairment. Now, we said hookworm is a parasite,
parasite is actually a form of symbiosis, which is
where two organisms live in really close contact
with each other. In particular, parasitism is what
we call a plus/minus form, that means that of the
two organisms involved in that symbiotic event,
so the two organisms here being the hookworm
and its host, one of those organisms benefits
from the symbiosis, the benefitter here would
be the hookworm, and then the other organism is
harmed and of course in the case of all events of
parasitism, the one being harmed is the host.
If you are interested in symbiosis and about
learning more about parasitism and other forms of
symbiosis, including mutualism and commensalism,
please see my video on the different types
of symbiosis. But to continue here, let's
now talk about the lifecycle of hookworm. Now a
hookworm infection begins with an egg. Now eggs,
hookworm eggs are shed in human feces, so an
infected host has hookworms inside them, their
feces will contain huge, huge numbers of hookworm
eggs. And this is actually the diagnostic stage,
meaning that you can take a fecal sample from a
person and actually see under a microscope all of
the different eggs in the feces, and so that's how
a hookworm infection is typically diagnosed. Now,
these eggs, if they make it into soil, they
can actually hatch in the warm soil into the
next developmental stage which is larvae, and they
need warm soil to do this and this is why hookworm
is typically thought of as a tropical disease
because it's those tropical temperatures that
allow the favorable conditions necessary for
the eggs to hatch into larvae. Now this early
larval form has a particular name, it's called
the rhabditiform stage of the larvae. Now, over
the course of a couple of weeks, the rhabditiform
form larvae will mature into a more mature form,
the larval stage here is called filariform, and
these larvae can actually survive approximately
three to four weeks in the soil. And that is
when conditions are particularly favorable,
so when temperature and moisture conditions are
right. Now, it is these filariform larvae that
can actually burrow through the host skin. So here
we have a picture, a drawing, of a human foot and
these larvae can actually burrow right through
the skin. Now the larvae are going to be able to
burrow through whatever skin is most in contact
with the soil, which of course is where they're
living, and so typically this is done when a human
goes barefoot and has their bare foot in contact
with the soil. Now once this larvae enters the
human body, it goes through a really circuitous
route. First, it enters the bloodstream, from the
bloodstream it moves to the heart, from the heart
it can travel through the body to the lungs,
and then the larvae actually gets coughed up,
so it gets coughed up from the lungs, up
to the pharynx, and then it gets swallowed,
and goes to the stomach. And the larvae that
survives the stomach acid conditions make it to
the small intestines, and it is here in the small
intestine where the larvae mature into adults.
So the larvae mature into adult worms. These adult
worms are the ones that then attach to the lining
of the small intestine and suck blood. They can
stay there for years and during the time that
they are alive within the body, they're constantly
laying eggs, huge huge numbers of eggs that then
get excreted from the human body in the feces and
then the cycle can continue. Now, luckily hookworm
has been all but eradicated in most developed
nations and this is for a few different reasons.
First, we have anti-helminthic drugs, so these are
drugs that fight worm infections. We can also take
iron pills to counteract the anemia that comes
from the blood loss. And then we can also break
this this chain of transmission by doing sort
of two main things: encouraging people to wear
shoes and making sure that everybody has shoes,
this is of course a bigger problem in various
developing nations, and also we can break this
chain of transmission in another place as well
and that's right here: making sure that the
human feces that contains the eggs does not
actually get into soil. And of course this can
be done when countries have proper sanitation
and public health infrastructure, and that's why
we don't really hear about hookworm in the United
States anymore but certainly it is a bigger
problem in many other parts of the world and
you can see that from the number who are infected.
Now, if you are interested in learning about other
types of parasite life cycles, please see my other
video which is on the life cycle of the parasite
that causes the the disease schistosomiasis,
and that's another kind of worm parasite so
check that one out if you're interested.
Thanks for watching Biology Professor! :)